Lets have huge round of applause for Ola
Oh, boy.
Thank you so much.
You are amazing.
Come on, okay.
Welcome to like the very last talk of the
side track of 2018.
Who has enjoyed the conference so far?
Right?
Who lost their voice?
Nice.
And if you need medicine.
So, my name is Ola.
I'm an engineer at Mozilla.
You might have heard.
I do mostly performance, compatibility, specs,
CSS, JavaScript, just the cool stuff.
Today we are going understand how TCP works.
Surprise.
It's delivered in the packages that everyone
is talking about, how it is.
And maybe we learn what happens to the ones
that are lost.
Okay.
Let's jump right back in.
Let's take a look at Internet protocol family.
You might recognize one or two of them.
And it has just a very few memories like it's
fine.
So, those you see here are probably the most
common.
Do you recognize any like HTP, STP, SMTP,
and when you're as old as I am they're cool.
And there are also different models that group
them together to make the roles kind of more
understandable.
This works on the model which groups the protocols
in seven layers.
It groups the protocols in different layers
for the interactive network layer, application
layer, totally makes sense, right?
And the most important one, the eighth layer.
Everyone forgets, but it's the hardest?
People.
There's also the DOD layer model.
It stands for Department of Defense because
they developed them.
Four layers, but it's kind of the most common
in our daily architecture.
The groups of protocols are in a little bit
different way.
You can see the relations in the graphics.
And the relationship model is there.
The DOD layer model is also called the TCP/IP
model.
They are both the foundational protocols.
So what do they even do?
I don't know.
So, what are those?
IP is short for Internet protocol.
It's here to give the sender and receiver
kind of numbers so the packages know where
they're coming from and where to go.
Like this one.
We could also go with names like bar, school,
park.
But computers are not that good with words.
So, we stick with numbers.
Another thing it does is actually to check
for like the closest router to forward the
data to.
You have a package, you're like, you!
Catch.
And we'll be fine.
TCP is short for transmission control protocol.
As the physical network, surprise, it's kind
of not reliable.
This protocol is taking care of the transmissions
of the data.
So, it creates a reliable network for you.
Makes sure everything gets from one point
to another.
Especially with something so wibbly and wobbly
like the physical network, it's good to have.
At least the sharks stopped chewing on the
under sea fiber cables.
That's a good thing.
What does TCP do?
Make sure your data arrives in a specific
order.
Make sure your data has like minimal errors
so it's actually correct.
Make the data, scale it.
Make sure lost packages are resent.
And protects the network from being overloaded.
We'll get to that later.
What it does not do?
It just doesn't care who is sending and receiving,
kind of.
It's just this cute little bear which is like,
yay!
Package.
[ Laughter ]
So, do you understand the roles?
Yes?
It's late.
Wake up.
Yes!
Woohoo!
I like that.
That's really good.
So, we get to the next point.
Packages.
I'm going to tell a story, make things easier.
So, imagine, your friend is sick.
Mm shit happens.
This is a good friend.
So, you want to borrow their book because
you like to read.
This is a book.
And you can't go there, and your roommate
will just basically grab this book and bring
it there.
So, this is what they do.
The roommate takes the book, bikes over.
Your friend is super happy.
They come back.
Congratulations!
You just delivered a package.
Okay, okay.
But your friend is like really sick.
Like uhchg you don't to want go there.
So, your room rate is really cool.
And you decide just to put together like a
small package to make them feel better.
You grab some tea and candy and cookies.
So, sort it into three boxes.
Those you bought at Ikea ten years ago in
the back of your cupboards, right?
And your friend is really sick and might forget
they got three and which one is that's fine.
Your roommate grabs them, bikes over.
Your friend is like, that's so nice of you,
thank you.
Puts in a small note for you.
Comes back.
Sounds reasonable?
Right?
You just understood how a round trip works.
Good job.
So, those packages are nothing else than boxes
that contain like candy, tea, cookies.
But, well, data.
Whatever.
Their focus is just basically to group the
bytes.
And every box is a number so you know the
order and especially if all of them arrived.
That's cool.
Okay.
We got that now.
So, now the most important and biggest part
we need to try to understand how actually
the transfer works.
And explaining this with data is kind of boring,
right?
>> Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So boring.
OLA: Who likes pancakes?
Raise your hand!
Pancakes everyone loves pancakes.
They can't be split up in small units, you
can slap stuff on it, whatever you want.
It's amazing.
They can stay in the boxes and fresh.
So, let's stick with pancakes.
Every transfer starts with a so called three
way handshake.
The three way handshake is here to make sure
both sides are like the correct ones and that
the file transfer actually happens.
This is how a three way handshake looks like.
Might remember from school.
We have a sender, receiver, things happen,
people get scared.
It's correct, but I don't like that much.
So, I was in a playground the other day.
I was reading this really good book.
I do read a lot.
And my 6 year old was like, what are you reading?
TCP.
Triple handshake.
Explain it to me.
I did.
She's like, mom, this is easy.
I'm going to build a port now.
I want to make you feel the same way.
We'll get there.
So, let's translate this in human.
So, let's meet our sender and receiver.
This is Stephan.
He's an engineer who loves biking and cooking
for others.
This is Dominik.
Also an engineer who likes to travel and because
we travels so much, home cooked meals.
Both of them have other things in common like
speaking at conferences, wearing onesies.
And especially, surprise!
Right?
Okay.
So, imagine, Stephan
[ Laughter ]
Stephan has made some pancakes.
Dominik wants some.
But they both really want to be sure that
the transfer works because Henri is not anyone
they want to speak to.
That's the neighbor.
And the pancakes arrive at the correct destination
through a handshake.
Stephan picks a random number, 23 it is.
Writes it on a piece of paper.
This is called a sync.
A request to synchronize.
Dominik takes a look at the note.
Performs the ack, which stands for acknowledgment.
He adds the number 1.
To let Stephan know that he received the note,
he thinks about number 2, but pancakes.
And it's hard.
He gets there.
He takes seven.
He sends that out, note goes back to Stephan
and he performs the ack.
That's one to Dominik's number.
And we're good to send those pancakes.
Nom, nom.
And these notes, they're not just love notes,
they're the TCP headers.
They contain all the information that the
TCP package needs.
This is how they look in real life.
Naw.
Yeah.
Let's see this.
Cool.
Let's take a look at the TCP headers the moment
Dominik sends it back to Stephan, right?
The same support is Dominik, destination support,
Stephan.
Dominik's random number was 7.
The sequence number is also 7.
When data was transferred the length of the
data in bit would have been added to that
number, to the sequence number.
But we didn't.
We did just a handshake, so, it saves the
7.
7 and 23, we got an ack, plus 21, acknowledge
number.
And the next dataset which pins down exactly
where the TCP header ends and the package
starts.
Reserve means 3 bits for new and just the
sum of it next to it already like sim, ack.
It contains the size of the data the sender
or receiver can handle.
So, the size of a pancake batch.
Depending on the direction, it's either the
one from the receiver or the sender.
Right?
So, we get back to that later.
Check for a minimum possible security effort.
Urgent pointers.
Possibility to say, hey, that package is more
important than the others.
Fast forward.
Hint?
Don't.
Options like, details, urgent and other things.
Options are good.
We like to have options.
So, it's a great performance improvement.
We assume 23 32 bits.
And if the header doesn't fill up.
The cool thing is we don't have to calculate
bit by bit by bit, just by steps.
And that helps.
Data with pancakes, right?
That's the blue ones you see here we talked
about already.
The yellow ones we'll take a closer look at.
So, pancakes and size of the batch.
And the green ones are a little bit more advanced.
Very interesting, but we're not going to do
this today.
So, you might have noticed Stephan and Dominik.
Say hello!
[ Applause ]
Right?
Hi.
So, as I mentioned, Dominik is hungry.
[ Laughter ]
How would you feel about if we actually fed
him pancakes?
Like here and now?
I mean, I'm a parent.
I always have a fresh batch of pancakes in
my bag.
But okay.
Before this, we really want to make sure he
does not overeat and get sick.
This is why we need to check how many pancakes
he can actually eat without getting sick.
And TCP, this mechanism is called flow control.
It's here to prevent the sender from overwhelming
the receiver with pancakes.
Possible reasons are Dominik is busy right
now with getting some cutlery, right?
Or
[ Laughter ]
He got some cutlery.
That's amazing.
It's a heavy load because I'm scared he's
receiving some berries and maple syrup and
maybe some bacon from someone.
I don't know.
And another transfer.
Or he's just got a very fixed amount of buffer
that translates in human as a plate can hold
just that many pancakes, right?
So, here you can see a very simplified version.
Usually it looks like this.
We don't have enough space.
Let's stick with this.
Cool.
Dominik receives pancakes but doesn't send
anything right now except a love letter, right?
Cool.
And that note will store the value for how
many pancakes he can put on Dominik's plate
per package.
Make sure he doesn't overeat.
Cool.
But he still gets as much food as possible.
For every ack that all the pancakes have arrived,
this number is on the note.
This note is receive window size, which is
like the available buffer space, plate.
Dominik knows every round trip how many pancakes
he can receive and how much space he's got
left.
Same goes for Stephan, if we would receive,
I don't know, some bacon maybe.
But I'm sorry, buddy.
I don't think you will.
Today the maximum possible value is 1 gigabyte.
It used to be 64 kilobytes.
A little bit small.
And it's because of the network round trip
time.
And this is hard to remember.
Just imagine, like, 1 gigabyte is one plate.
Okay.
Wait.
What about the sender in the network?
That's important, right?
Come on.
Two minutes.
We don't want to overwhelm them.
So, this is why we have congestion window
size.
CWN short.
They are not send, just known.
They're just known by the person that sends
them out.
This defines how many segments can be sent
out per package.
We'll get back to that later.
So, this is kind of a batch of pancakes.
They're measured in so called TCP protocol
data units defined by the connection they're
actually using.
So, a batch of pancakes is smaller when you
use more of them, and bigger, when you use
a fiber cable connection.
The window size can never be bigger than the
receiver window size.
Because a plate can have just so many pancakes.
So, round trip, the congestion window size
keeps increasing up to the maximum receiver
window size until the network reaches its
limit or you don't have anything left to send.
Does it make sense?
Awesome.
It's good that you're awake.
Because now we can transfer a transfer.
And look.
Everyone who sits in between them, welcome.
You're the data pipeline.
So, how it works.
You start the package.
You do your stuff.
As fast as possible.
It's all about performance, right?
We need a small round trip time.
Okay.
First pancakes.
Let's go, let's go.
Keep them in the package.
That's fine.
Come on, we don't have much time.
Too close.
Go, go, go!
Faster!
Dominik got them!
Come on, come on!
Ack!
Got the ack, come back.
Don't even close it.
It's all about the performance.
Now come on, come on!
Ahhhh!
This takes forever.
And the next batch and the next batch, faster,
faster, faster.
Now, by the way, we are four segments.
We increased because he is eating.
So, what's the receiver window size right
now?
Ack.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool.
We got that down.
That's really good.
Faster!
Look.
That is faster than you.
Look!
And come on.
The last round trip.
The last one.
Wait.
Did someone steal pancakes?
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
They're mine now.
We can talk this over, by the way.
It's like a big applause for everyone.
Thank you so much.
Good job.
That was so nice.
So, you might have realized two things.
Except hopefully are you okay now?
Pancake?
Yeah, cool.
Ack.
So, there were two things you might have recognized.
One was, we actually kind of increased the
segments, rights?
Round trip, you totally saw that.
The other was package loss.
Okay.
Second and first one.
This is random, the increase of pancakes.
Was it random?
Surprise.
No, this mechanism is optimized for TCP.
What it does is estimate available capacity
between like the sender and receiver.
How?
Available capacity by exchanging data.
So, do you mean I was talking about segments,
right?
Batch of pancakes?
Do you see they arrived and get the congestion
size to not overwhelm the network or the sender.
They never start with the full bandwidth.
They are show and small and figure out how
big the network is and how much it can handle.
First of all you start this.
So, you have time and status of pancakes.
Congestion control.
Window.
Congestion window size.
Default today.
And the default is 10.
It used to be 4.
We did 2.
It was just easy.
Let's go with that.
So, here the value, you can see here, is 2.
Right?
So, when we received everything, you get an
ack.
And we measure it round trip time.
The other is incremental.
It doubles up and then we can look forward
and do the same.
When everything arrives, it's an ack.
Round trip time measured and then 8 and 16.
This is how it looked like.
I just explained to you.
Let's assume that this is the last pancakes,
right?
At 16.
Okay.
TCP has the packages, it's awesome, loves
you, takes care of you.
Right?
But it will probably fail again because it
can't have that many segments.
So package loss, surprise, is not a bad thing.
It's a bit in mechanism.
The task is that we are overwhelmed for the
network to avoid losing like more packages
in the network.
We have something called congestion avoidance.
Feedback Mel mechanism, package loss, showed
us all along the way that something a congested
link or router.
That's why we need to at just the CWN, right?
So, what we do is we check out which was the
last value that worked.
Resets our CWN ending back to than and we
will go from that.
Run into package at some point again.
Do the algorithm again, then.
We'll just adjust.
So, latest value that worked was 8, right?
We take that and don't double it up.
We just take half of it and put it on.
Before, and then 12 plus 6 and goes on until
we lose packages again.
The algorithm is like the really tricky part
here.
When it's too aggressive, it's cutting down
the increase and your, well, connection.
Pretty bad.
If you don't adjust quickly enough, right?
Then it will introduce more package loss.
So a PRR is really cool because those algorithms
are repeatedly and constantly worked on.
And this is one of the good algorithms that
might cut off like 3 10% of your round trip
time.
And it's really nice.
So, all of that sounds amazing.
Do you love TCP?
[Cheers]
There are limitations.
So, I lost my thoughts.
Every time we hit the limit and wait for the
ack, that's like one round trip time of delay.
Right?
Either the sender or the receiver are forced
to stop and wait for the ack.
And that, if it's like a very long time, it
can cause like massive gaps in the data flow.
So, that is called bandwidth delay product.
This is like the bottleneck, and the connection
is unreliable, the times can vary.
The good idea here is to optimize your window
size value so that the round trip time will
be enough to get the ack back.
And the bigger the loss without the package
loss, the better.
And you can use window scaling because it
helps you with that.
Since TCP is an abstraction off of a reliable
network over an unreliable connection.
And it has like really cool features, we talked
about.
Like, basic page error checking were order
delivery, retransmission of lost packages,
package control and avoidance.
And they are built for the best efficiency
possible.
But they limit what you can do when something
is specially made for something else.
Head of line blocking is the last imitation
I would like to point out.
As we have like a reliable and auto delivery
built in, we kind of rely on all segments
to arrive.
So, when the three segments are sent out and
the first or one of those is lost, it will
drop all packages.
So, the first one was lost.
This was waiting for the first one and everything
afterwards, no, no, no.
First one.
I don't care about the others.
So, Stephan will basically resend the packages.
Until the first one arrives, then the second,
then the third.
And we get an ack.
This might cause like a connection to die
at some point because we will be overwhelmed
with resending.
And there's no way around this.
And consider something else if you don't need
a reliable and ordered network.
And please don't build stuff because you think,
it's great, I need a very few features.
You will realize after like six months, whoops!
I've rebuilt TCP.
Okay.
I had an amazing ending for you.
But I had the package called actually lost.
Thank you.